hatten doch mal ende juni anfang juli an
manchen tagen 300 neue infektionen und
wir haben jetzt an manchen tagen 2400
infektionen und das heißt nichts anderes
als dass ich über juli august september
in drei monaten die infektionszahlen
dreimal verdoppelt haben 300 auf 600 600
auf 1200 1200 auf 2400 und wenn das in
den nächsten drei monaten oktober
november dezember weiter so wäre dann
würden wir von 2400 auf 4800 auf 9.600
auf 19.200 kommen und daran wollte ich
nur zeigen und das ist ja das wesen des
exponentiellen anstiegs dass die
verdopplung zeit wenn sie die gleiche
bleibt trotzdem land zu sehr großen
fallzahlen führt und das ist
unterstreicht die dringlichkeit dass wir
handeln und zwar dort handeln wo wir ein
solches wieder ins exponentielle gehende
wachstum haben mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schaue ich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren